And in the conservative world has to be
careful. This podcast could sink a ship.
I'm pro nuance. Yeah. How'd you
come up with a shirt pro nuance.
I know. Shit. Listen, I think the way
that I came up with it is because in the,
in the hunting world there is this,
speaking of conservative,
there's this like there's the conservative
traditional district and there's the
more progressive folks that
you have met and been around.
You've been around both, but it'd be
around both Eder more environmentalist's,
more public lands, more access.
Right. So there's kind of like to,
of course there's always two sides of
politics, but they're just in this case,
two distinct sides,
right?
And the line kind of gets drawn
around one a little bit around guns,
but also a little bit around
the environment. So part
of the biggest issue in,
in politics for a hunter angler right
now is like, I really like guns.
I like the second amendment.
I dig what's going on there.
I'd like to support that.
But what I also like is healthy
ecosystems and environment and I,
and I like habitat for wild game to
live. And public lands and access. Well,
it just so happens that a lot of the a
plus rated politicians for the NRA are
like f minus or a d plus rated in
protecting wildlife and wild lands.
And a lot of that's around extraction
and different things like that.
But extraction
minerals and oil and natural
from valuable lands. Right.
So then change the way
these lands are scheduled.
What it's under.
Yeah. I mean there was a lot of
action. This is our around monuments,
of course that was one big one,
but it's,
it's just around like the general basis
of even as a hunter, but all Americans.
But as a hunter, I'm faced with like
I love wildlife, I love wild places,
clean water, clean
lands, I'm all for that.
That's a huge part of what I believe that.
But I also believe in
the second amendment.
I believe in my rights
to defend my family.
I believe in my right to to own
firearms and to, and to do that.
So I believe in those two things, but
because our politics are the way they are,
it doesn't leave room for those two
beliefs. When I'm at at the voting booth,
sometimes not all the time,
hardly leaves room for those beliefs
in normal conversations with people,
unless you absolutely know that the
person's going to be objective and as your
shirt says pro nuance this,
that the idea that you,
you shouldn't be able to defend your
family is where it gets crazy. Yeah.
It doesn't get crazy that you want
to be able to defend your family.
Like why do these movies all have
robberies and breakins and bad guys?
Well, why did you visit a real
things? It's a real thing.
So the idea that you should just be a
sitting duck because there's so many crazy
fucks out there that want to shoot
up schools and go on mass shootings.
It somehow or another you
are being conflated with
them that you're going to be
being got confused with them or categorize
with them. Like how, how is that?
These are different things.
They are just both involve guns.
They are their things.
It's like the insole that drove all of
those people in Toronto. I remember that.
Yup. You know what? If that keeps
happening. That's happened many times.
You've seen people kill people
cars over the last few years.
It's been like four or five big events.
Are they mutually exclusive?
Like I want to be able to defend my
family and own firearms and have that
freedom. That's big part of this country.
But I also don't want people to die.
Exactly. In mass shootings.
I don't want that.
I want worse on the other side of
the coin with when it comes to like
environmental issues and around hunting
public lands and things of that nature.
I want coal miners to have jobs.
I want people that work in an extraction
industries to have an opportunity to
work and live and do what they need to do.
But I also want to protect our ecosystems
at all costs because you can't replace
that shit.
Right.
And there's gotta be other jobs out there.
If the government put its resources
instead of propping up old ways of doing
business that pollute the environment
versus new ways of doing business are
certain cities and with with government
programs, that's entirely possible.
Yeah.
There are certainly reasonable and and
healthy ways to mine copper or are there
ways to, I don't know. There is, I mean
there's responsible ways to do that,
but at what, at what costs? You're
still, you're still extracting,
right? You're still
doing something, do it.
You're still changing the
natural environment there.
Yeah. Someone was trying to make that,
that argument with fracking with me.
I was talking to him about that.
Is it Josh Fox's documentary? Um,
what is, uh, he, he was
on the podcast, the um,
something fracking nation.
What was his, uh, he made a,
it was a very good documentary and it
was when I had him on the podcast was
interesting because he seemed like he
had been attacked a lot for it and even
misunderstood.
Like some of the questions I was asking,
like maybe they were coming from me
and I will say, no, this is just like,
what was it called? Fractionation? What
does it, yes. Gaslamp. That's it. Oh yeah.
I said, okay. It's um, it's disturbing.
Like you're watching some aspects of it,
like when they were wedding lighting,
their water on fire and then
someone tried to say, oh,
there's some places where you've always
been able to let your water on fire,
and I was like, okay, wait, okay,
the lighting your water on size.
Real argument that someone
said that that's not really
from fracking and I said,
okay, these people said that there
was no lighting, the water on fire.
Then people started fracking.
The water smell like shit.
They started lighting on fire though.
You're saying those are not connected?
Well, over the years, Joe,
we've been able to light our water
on fire for a number of reasons,
but 4th of July
I would think to be confident about that,
and I'm not confident about it,
but to be confident about what that
guy said to me when he was saying that,
it's always been like that.
You would have to have
done massive research.
You would have to spent time there.
You would have to been working either
directly or indirectly with the scientists
that are collecting the data. You'd have
to get it from them. You'd have to know,
you'd have to see it,
you'd have to make sure was sure.
Or you have to be a person who is
not interested in the actual truth.
They just have an idea that they want to
push through. And this is a weird thing.
Certain right wing folks,
there's a weird thing they want to
push through that business is good and
environmentalist are all pussies and
hippies and Weirdos and losers and these
things don't jive in the world of someone
who actually loves and appreciates the
actual earth of course,
man, because weird. But
there is no way that anyone
could argue, right? There's,
there's in the hunting world
or something like access and,
and public land and all these
things become a big deal.
But you can define access in a
ton of different ways. To me,
accessible to me,
access could be I like wilderness or
did the only way you can access it is on
foot via, via trailhead.
Someone else might say,
access to me is uh,
elderly folks or disabled folks bail them
to get on into a car and drive through
a road and public land. Or,
or get into an ATV and drive.
And so politics are being what they are.
Politicians take this term of access.
It happened around national monuments.
They take one side said the president
is stealing your land and the other side
says,
the president is giving back your land.
Somebody there either both sides
are full of shit or one of them is,
I remember when this came up,
Patagonia,
which is a giant company
in the trap doors,
had a big ad on the Internet that said
the president just stole your land.
And then I heard Rinella talk about, and
he said, this is, I'm going to paraphrase,
but he basically said, if you say
that the presence until your land,
you're not being careful with your
words. Yes. And you're not being asked.
You're being inflammatory. Yes. You're
being absolutely inflammatory. Yeah.
Because it's not again,
that that you're talking about grand
staircase Escalante in bears ears,
National Monument bears
ears being in Utah,
being explained to people what
happened the boy, um, I'll,
I'll do my best. Thank you Ben. So,
so the antiquities act,
let's get back to the antiquities act
to protect the antiquities act is to
protect, um, culturally
or socially, emotionally,
culturally significant pieces of land,
all the way to things like
the Grand Canyon. Right?
And so spin it up to the end of,
there's a lot that I just skipped over,
but I'm going to spin it up to the
end of the Obama administration.
President Obama used his executive
power to protect large swaths,
millions of acres around that bow around
bears ears national monument to protect
not only the, the significant
places for native Americans and for,
um,
native tribesman around bears ears,
but many millions of acres around that.
And so then it becomes the problem
I have in the why that kind of,
that tee shirt exists. It becomes a
political football throw back and forth.
It's not at this point in time
what's best for bears ears,
what's best for that national monument.
It was best for,
for it to be fairly owned. What's best
for the people, the jobs, the place.
It becomes what's best for
each side and their rhetoric.
And so president Trump asked secretary,
former secretary of Interior
Ryan Zinky to review,
I think it was like 10 monuments to see
if they should be reduced based on the
predictions that Obama had put put into
place. So he reviews these 10 monuments.
He cuts out eight of them
and hones in on two places,
bears ears and grand staircase Escalante.
They then say,
we're going to reduce the
size of these monuments.
When you say cuts out eight of them,
what do you mean by cuts out?
They review the other eight and say
they're fine. They're good to go,
no changes necessary. Okay. Some
would say they did that as a,
as a straw men as eight strawmen to knock
them over and look at these other two.
They said we will reduce the PR,
the,
the area that is designated
as a national monument.
And here again,
it comes to both sides.
They would say because President Obama
wielded his powers corruptly to protect,
to be as an environmentalist,
to protect lands that didn't need
protected under the antiquities act.
Because the antiquities act does say it
should be the smallest acreage possible
to protect.
So now you get into stuff that I'm not
an expert in and around legal jargon and
going back to things that were written
in the 1930s but we get to a point where
one side saying,
here is the Republicans trying to shrink
down these monuments so that they can
then go the companies that are can then
go and lease these places for mining,
but they can't currently do on their
protections as a national monument.
The other side is saying,
we're trying to protect
culturally significant lands
and these millions of acres
need protected.
They need protection for lots of reasons.
So you end up with
those two sides talking.